my father cannot fight
so i will take his place everybody loves
mulan they love the story when i told
people i was doing the junket they were
like
i have to know what you thought so why
do you think people are so
attached to this particular princess
story
oh look this story has been around since
the seventh century
so there is something so potent about it
that has kept that's captivated people
for centuries
and and i think it's her it's her
humanity
it's her courage um
but it's her love you know her
her journey hiro's journey certainly
everything she does
she does out of love for her family
her desire to bring honor to them and to
need to save her father's life and and
and that selflessness
i think is very inspiring i feel like
why is mulan so important to so many
people is
i see her not just as a hero but first
human and i think that's movie
itself is a universal language
but the the humanity is also something
everybody could feel
and the journey to be
true to herself and to
experience the not as true and then to
still have the courage to find the way
home
yeah it's so whatever whenever do fight
scenes or white horse
it's not just it has to do what happened
before and
what's happening in her history so that
makes
the fight and all the action uh make
sense
excellent um and nikki you got to
choreograph some amazing
um fight performers with donnie and jett
and yfay
i just want to know like was that the
reason why you think this is the one
that had to be pg-13 because you knew
you wanted to up the ante with
both like the you know the fight
sequences and just how dramatic it was
is that why
yes yes it's it's it's a very
adrenalized
version of uh mulan
um certainly for people who are more
familiar with the animation
by bringing it into live action you know
we have the opportunity to make
the action really explosive and and
thrilling
um but with that we also have
the emotion and um and the humor we're
trying to do it all here
it's a movie yeah i think it's so great
like to do this interview on
you know women's day when i was talking
to johnny and jet they talked about
your crew and how like the dp was female
makeup and
camera operators and so how does it feel
to be like the first you know woman to
really tell one of these stories
so like a huge disney movie that's got
to be just incredible
yeah it is and you know i'm really
inspired by
mulan herself and that and
and her commitment to being herself to
she's not powerful until she sheds the
disguise of being a
young man and fights as a woman
and and as herself and i feel the same
for me
you know i directed this enormous movie
to this huge epic vision but as myself
as a woman and i had a lot of women
with me to tell that story this is very
female-lit
so on international women's day
it makes it's very satisfying to me to
say
this is what we do actually
when they find out who you are they will
show
you no mercy
[Music]
what was your first experience with
mulan because like a lot of folks for me
it was the animated but what about you
oh when we grew up
we already know the story in china
everybody knows mulan you know
because the character everybody chinese
mind
say you know you need a loyalty to the
country
you need a devotion to your family so
the two things it's really difficult to
put together
usually action film you need a loyalty
fight
be the bad guy so that's a memory
even my daughter they grew up i don't
know where they heard
mulan they just love their idol you know
yeah was your daughter's a reason why
you maybe wanted to do this a little bit
because you know be like yeah yeah in
the beginning i don't want to take the
movie you know
and then my daughter said
ask three questions while you turn down
the movie as okay
she say first did you think
promote chinese culture is your
responsibility in your life
i said yes he said disney
spent a million hundred million dollar
dollar
put all the actors in china the chinese
actor you know then the storytalk of
moonlight is not a chinese culture
oh like stocked nice okay
the second do you need a lot of money
she's watching not
third can you make the movie for me
that's it i'm so glad that he put me
there you know
work with wonderful group the result
i think even everybody know mulan but
this mulan have a lot of fresh new
angle to share the culture to the
younger generation yeah that's what i
loved is how like
it's its own thing um what are you most
excited for
like this like crop of film fans to see
in this version that
maybe they don't know is coming when
they see it because
you know there have a lot of culture
with a lot of angle
you know millions millions of people
everybody in their mind have
one kind of mulan you cannot make
everybody happy
you know you make chinese easter you
know everybody is happy
but i think human is like a
big family we're living in the earth but
this mulan
i think across the border can show to
the younger
girls to the world everybody need to be
tough loyalty in a truth you know
faced to the difficult time i think thai
is wonderful
it's international mulan this is not the
only traditional for traditional chinese
mulan
that's a i love it director everybody
did a wonderful job
yeah i know i i completely agree they
also had me like crying
also i'm not gonna lie watching it i was
like gently like they had me tricking on
you
but i couldn't tell it was you but uh
but i
the minute i saw you fighting i was like
oh there he is um and then i saw donnie
fighting and of course i'm like okay
there he is but
i'm just wondering you know you guys
re-teaming did y'all maybe
get together on set you know see who
could do the cooler moves maybe
no no no not this time before you know
we're best friends
always call each other you've been
serving before so you take the most part
i take it apart we need to do it we're
not you know we discuss
but really work on the side i only saw
her once
yeah yeah i my character in this movie
just talk
more than facting he did a wonderful job
he's a good guy
yeah both of y'all did an absolutely
wonderful job and
i have to ask this one although i'm sure
you've been asked it a lot of times
who wins on the one-on-one you and
donnie
i have my bet but i'm not gonna say oh
who want to fight the best
yeah who's gonna win on the one-on-one
what is your name soldier waging
[Music]
we're going to make men out of every
single one of you
[Music]
you've had some great entrances your
entrance in this one is absolutely i
think like
i haven't seen the film so i don't know
you haven't seen it i haven't
felt like i have a little secret well
i mean but you you shot it so talk about
like the fighting styles in this you've
done so many different types of fight
choreography but i feel like with this
particular
film like nikki was going for something
like really specific
on camera uh he she told me
exactly what she envisioned and she
wanted
how i play off mulan
i mean that's ultimately it's about the
the movie
itself right so for me i i just did my
job you know like any other movies i
came in with
as an actor professional actor
understanding the role and
and i performed and she liked it
well obviously it's pretty great i can't
wait for you to see it because i think
you're gonna agree with me you have a
great time on it
um this uh mulan the legend is like kind
of like
throughout chinese culture and like like
you don't even probably remember the
first time
you heard the legend i'm guessing like
it was probably when you were a kid is
that when you first like heard it
of course this is based on the chinese
folk story uh
history part of the chinese culture but
more importantly
my daughter grew up with this the
cartoon version disney version so i know
all the songs inside
with my daughter and we sang probably
over 100 times
so for me it's part of
her childhood as well as my younger days
yeah
jen mentioned that his daughters were a
big reason why he said yes to do the
movie same here
exactly the same um and then he said
that you guys did you all call each
other
make sure that yes are you doing the
film i said yeah are you doing the film
i said i got it
uh he also said that he was a little
jealous that you got to do more fighting
than he did he says his role is a little
bit more talking
actually i wish it's the other way
around
i want to sit back and just kind of
watch
ife do her thing right but they want
me to swing that sword around so i i did
um i agree with you that they did want
you to swing the sword around i enjoyed
that a lot
um what are you most excited about for
folks to see with this particular mulan
especially like
what nikki did with the story because
it's it's very different but it's
amazing
i think uh to to to make it short
i think um first of all you have to live
up with the
the love for this uh peace
from disney because we all love disney
but i think
particularly mulan everyone loves mulan
they represent a certain
in our era
especially now the metoo movement like i
think it's so important to show the
world that
female can do anything male can
i know firsthand because my my mother
she was a grandmaster in martial arts
she used to teach in boston and
she was my mentor as well as i have a
daughter
a very powerful young lady and my
production company my partner my wife
which totally changed my life
and she's my boss so i know how it is
you know as
a uh the other part of
uh the gender women are just
simply beautiful so this represents a
whole lot
i'm hua mulan i will bring honor to us
[Music]
all